♪
>> PROSECUTOR’S ROLE IS TO SEE
THAT JUSTICE IS DONE AND JUSTICE
IS SERVED WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN ELDERLY AND
VULNERABLE ADULT DEATH REVIEW
BOARD.
IF ANYONE THINKS THEY’RE ABOVE
THE LAW IN THIS ADMINISTRATION,
THINK AGAIN.
JEDEDIAH: MICHIGAN’S PROSECUTOR
CALLING FOR A COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW GOVERNOR GRETCHEN
WHITMER’S DEADLY NURSING HOME
POLICY IN THE STATE.
OUR NEXT GUEST LOST HIS SISTER
MARY LAST YEAR IN A MICHIGAN
NURSING HOME AND IS DEMANDING
ACCOUNTABILITY.
ANTHONY, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR YOU FOR THE
LOSS OF YOUR SISTER MARY.
PLEASE, FIRST, TELL US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MARY AND HOW SHE
PASSED.
>> MARY, YOU KNOW, SHE ENTERED
THE NURSING HOME ABOUT 2014 DUE
TO THE A STROKE SHE HAD
SUFFERED.
AND THE OBJECTIVE FOR HER TO BE
IN THE NURSING HOME WAS A
REHABILITATION CENTER HOPING SHE
WOULD COME OUT IN TIME, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT WAS MARY’S
HOME.
SHE SUFFERED FROM TIME TO TIME
FROM URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS,
AND IN TURN -- THE LAST TIME I
HAD SAW HER WAS ON FEBRUARY
27TH, HER BIRTHDAY IN 2020.
AT THAT TIME SHE WAS ON A
SEDATIVE, SO I REALLY DIDN’T GET
A CHANCE, I KISSED HER, WISHED
HER A HAPPY BIRTHDAY, AND THAT
WAS THAT.
AND IT WASN’T UNTIL APRIL 6TH
THAT SHE WENT -- APRIL 16TH THAT
SHE WENT BACK INTO THE HOSPITAL,
AND I WAS TOLD TWO DAYS LATER
SHE HAD TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19 AND WAS HAVING TROUBLE
BREATHING.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, MY SISTER
THEN PASSED AWAY SIX DAYS LATER.
JEDEDIAH: THAT’S A REALLY
HORRIBLE THING TO HEAR.
LIKE I SAID, OUR HEARTS BREAK
FOR YOU.
WE’VE HEARD SO MANY STORIES FROM
FAMILIES WHO ARE IMPACTED BY
THESE NURSING HOME POLICIES.
SO, YOU KNOW, MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO GETS A
LOT OF COVERAGE FOR WHAT HE DID
IN NEW YORK WITH RESPECT TO THE
NURSING HOMES.
OTHER GOVERNORS AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN MAYBE NOT IDENTICAL, BUT
SIMILAR POLICIES THAT HAD
SIMILAR IMPLICATIONS DON’T GET
QUITE SO MUCH COVERAGE, AND
THERE ARE CONCERNS THEY MAY NOT
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT IN
TERMS OF THE PARALLEL BETWEEN
CUOMO AND WHITMER, AND DO YOU
THINK THERE WILL BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HER?
>> YOU KNOW, I REALLY DON’T WANT
TO SPECULATE ON THINGS THAT I
REALLY DON’T HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION.
I CAN SAY IS AND WILL SAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, WHEN MY SISTER PASSED
AWAY, EVERYTHING WAS HUSH HUSH.
MY SISTER WAS A WARD OF THE
STATE YEARS AGO, AND THERE WAS
ONLY LIMITED INFORMATION THAT WE
COULD GET.
OUR FAMILY WOULD LIKE ANSWERS.
ANSWERS THAT NOBODY HAS
RECEIVED.
ALSO ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND IF IT MEANS LIABILITY, IF
POSSIBLE, RAMIFICATIONS FOR
THINGS THAT THEY FEEL -- WHOEVER
THAT MAY BE, THAT CALLED THAT
SHOT TO SEND PEOPLE BACK TO THE
NURSING HOMES WHEN THEY ALREADY
KNEW THAT THEY LEFT THE HOSPITAL
POSITIVE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO GO TO
NEUTRAL ZONES IN DOWNTOWN
DETROIT, JOE LOUIS ARENA,
WHEREVER THE HUBS WERE AT FOR
THEM.
THEY DID --
[INAUDIBLE]
[AUDIO DIFFICULTY]
SEND THEM BACK TO THEIR
LONG-TERM FACILITIES.
AND WHEN THEY DID THAT,
BASICALLY --
[INAUDIBLE]
AND AS SHE ENTERED, IF YOU HAD
THE VIRUS, EVERYONE THAT YOU
CAME INTO CONTACT WITH -- AND,
UNFORTUNATELY, MY SISTER --
[INAUDIBLE]
JEDEDIAH: YES.
YEAH.
[AUDIO DIFFICULTY]
JEDEDIAH: YEAH.
ANTHONY IF, I HATE TO INTERRUPT
YOU, WE’RE UNFORTUNATELY RUNNING
OUT OF TIME, BUT THAT IS THE
POLICY IN QUESTION THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAD COVID-19 AND THOSE WHO
DID NOT WERE ESSENTIALLY GROUPED
IN THE SAME SPACES FOR PRETTY
MUCH A SIX MONTH PERIOD.
SO WE’RE HOPING FOR A FULL AND
COMPLETE INVESTIGATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ANYONE WHO
PLAYED A HAND IN POLICY THAT WAS
DETRIMENTAL TO YOU, AND WE ONCE
AGAIN GROOVE WITH YOU FOR THE